[Musique]
le soleil se lève sur les 9 122 hectares
de la forêt départementaux domaniale et
c'est déjà l'effervescence pour la 19ème
édition de la marche de la mutualité la
santé parce que quand on transpire quand
on fait du sport mels a fait c'est idéal
voit la santé mais une famille de sortir
sur l'ailé gauche ou licenciés dans son
sillage on est bien on est bien du
service à la demande et sans quoi c'est
bien de courir
une marche est celle que l'on doit ici
il ya des tissus et fillon ben nous
troisième âge on a l'habitude d'amener
notre chaise la marche est une heure
après on reste debout pendant 8 heures
alors projet en fait c'est vous qui avez
raison
voilà avec guillaume de toute l'île puis
de 3000 personnes sont venues bouger non
ce lieu fréquenté toute l'année entre
nous et littoral fait si on veut dire
elle est mise à disposition des
personnes qui veulent bien l'investir
dont le conseil départemental qui est
qui en est le gestionnaire à travers
l'eau nf est bien fait tout pour que cet
espace et espace à soi utilisées il soit
aussi mis à disposition de la population
une action encouragé par le département
et notamment pour ses actions de
prévention telles que le diabète et
cette année l'accent est mis sur la
protection solaire qui si on a la carte
d'elle de l'index uv moyen de la réunion
en décembre
donc c'est une échelle qui exprime le
degré de dangerosité des uv à un instant
t
donc la réunion en décembre n'est somme
toute la journée on a un coup de soleil
à partir de un quart d'heure on a
beaucoup de personnes à la réunion qui
pensent que les uv c'est quelque chose
auquel on est habitué qu'il est normal
qu on est naturellement protégée alors
sans compter maladie à la réunion que le
vieillissement de l'oeil on à la
cataracte
on a des maladies de la rétine aussi qui
vont apparaître
dix à quinze ans plus tôt qu'en
métropole au contraire on est beaucoup
plus sensible à l'aréna personnes à
mobilité réduite famille compétiteur il
y en a pour tous les goûts
[Applaudissements]
car pour marie odette le plus important
et ne pas trop s'écouter
[Applaudissements]
ces trains restés sur place ou si et
écouter la petite douleur parce que
sinon on sait toujours rien
c'est pour la santé pour mia moi parce
que je sais que je suis diabétique aussi
et depuis j'ai fait sur le sport
je suis bien et dans ce même sentier des
élus encourage cette action d'intérêt
collectif
quelles que soient les acteurs les
porteurs de projets le département est
là pour encourager ses actions parce que
c'est quand même aider la population qui
vient découvrir ses activités à mieux
vivre meilleure santé et à être dans en
pleine nature et faire naturellement cet
exercice physique pour le bien-être et
la française le discours est donc simple
mieux vivre mieux bouger mieux
s'alimenter
c'est donc à vous de jouer
[Musique]